back at the start of the 20th century
mathematicians were fascinated by the
question just how much maths can we do
not by using our gut feelings or
intuitions but just by following rules
very very carefully by following an
algorithm in order to make that notion
precise we would have to set out just
what do we mean by a program or
algorithm and this is where Alan Turing
came in with his notion of a Turing
machine cheering was working on a
problem in formal logic and as part of
his proof he had to come up with a
notion of any possible algorithm or any
possible machine he had to come up with
a very general way of capturing how
algorithms or programs or machines would
work this is where his notion of a
Turing machine comes in the wagering
described these machines goes like this
you have a way of writing down
information in a coded form his way was
to think of a tape which is as long as
it needs to be it's divided up into
squares and on each of these squares
there's either a 1 or a 0 or we can have
some spaces now what our machine does is
it looks at the tape one square at a
time so you could imagine it as a little
box running above the tape maybe on
little wheels looking one square at a
time and that information codes up a
question or a problem that we want
solved what the Turing machine does is
really simple at any moment in time it's
in a particular state and it's looking
at one square on the tape and it has a
logbook a program book and that tells it
if for instance you're in state number
23 and you're looking at 0 then rub out
the 0 change it to a 1 move one square
to the right and move into state number
359 for instance or
if you're in State number 359 and you're
looking at a one leave that one as it is
move one square to the left and move
into state number 20
really simple instructions what the
machine does is it starts off with a
certain pattern of ones and zeros it
follows these rules one square at a time
transforming that string of 1 and zeros
into a different string of ones and
zeros and eventually hopefully the
machine moves into a halting state it's
finished it's done and what's left on
the tape is the answer to our problem
coded up as ones and zeros that is such
a simple process but it turns out it's
the essence of computation whatever any
computer can do it could in theory be
done by that system looking at ones and
zeros on a tape so that's why we say
that Turing in coming up with this idea
of Turing machines in effect came up
with a blueprint for modern digital
computers those computers manipulate
strings of ones and zeros to solve
problems this really simple idea that we
find in during machines is actually so
powerful that all modern computers
basically do what during machines do and
we use this idea to evaluate the
strength of modern computer programs
when a computer program can do what a
Turing machine can do we call it
cheering complete and that is the top of
the hierarchy of program strength so the
strongest program that we can get does
exactly what a cheering machine can do
we've never come up with a way of
computing things that could do more than
a Turing machine so recently there's
been a challenge to the idea that
anything a computer can do a churring
machine can do and the challenge comes
from
quantum computers which almost seem like
they can do things magically my take on
this is that a quantum computer can't do
more than a Turing machine but it can do
things more efficiently for instance if
you asked a classical computer to find
you a phone number in the phone
directory you have to look through every
single entry takes a long time but a
quantum computer can do that more
efficiently don't ask me how
look what happens if I've read a zero
which I have there what do I then do the
answer is I overwrite it with a one call
that machine H for the halting problem
if you give me that machine I can
transform it into a different machine
like this